il est temps de passer à ce que vous
attendez tous étaient beaux à boîte de
noël je vous le dis la production
m'avait déconseillé de faire gagner
quelqu'un sur twitter mais ce que je
vais les écouter
non non forcément non si on vous dit ça
va brouiller pour le prime tout ça et
bien ça va rien brouillé du tout je vaux
freiner donc sur twitter hashtag bras
boîte plus le chroniqueur le nom d'un
chroniqueur et vous gagnerez la même
chose que lui ce soir dans les bois
boîte de noël il y a comme cadeau à un
déguisement de lutins fabien on a pris
en exemple un bouche à bouche c'est à
dire enfin un beau choc du bouche à
bouche une bûche alors une palette bus à
sextos de noël je vous dirais le sexto
dans un instant vous allez voir ça va
vous plaire vous devrez prendre une
personne très très incertain très très
importante dans votre agenda
elle a envoyé un texto isabelle bien
mais toi tu laisses les mains sur la
table on en verra ça bien entendu au
patron de m6 rien à elle déjà je joue
pas dépenser dès la phase la phase de
sapin vous verrez ce que c'est c'est
très sympa de l'avoir une phase de
sapins et ça va vous changer et il y
aura emma avec nos mouvements et marc
bien sûr qu'avec un lloris kid qui vous
chantera la chanson de mariah carey dans
les oreilles elle va vous flinguer la
gueule au beau cadeau il ya une tv être
une télé écran plat une console nouvelle
génération un robot de cuisine piqué le
salaire du jour de la personne à votre
droite mal donc toi c moi [ __ ]
et c'est là mais bon c'est edouard et du
fort en télé c'était ça c'est la
neuvième change nourrir bonjour aux
joues allez y à un week end au soleil
avec baba donc je freinais avec vous et
co animer un prime en 2020 avec moi
c'est bon tu t'es mis dans tous les
cadeaux toi tranquille tu pars au soleil
time croit co-animé reprennent avec un
goût tu crois que c'est un cadeau
merci alors s'il vous plaît je vais
démarrer
bien sûr les femmes par les femmes
alors les mains amies nationale et
malines valérie alors suite la lavande
que personne ne voulait faire ça oui
castaldi mais questionne la boîte
parfait oui
en 85 on ne faisait rien là bas et et
profitent pas du tout je te laisse pas
être marié je ne reviens je voudrais
bien la numéro 7 en ré numéro 7
alors on veut voir son art rock oh là là
où j'en ai acheté pourquoi ils sont pas
rangés aux réserves
oui alors vous l'a7 benhaim c'est ça
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'elle y met
kobena nas la nef je veux voir ce qu'on
a tous un petit 37,1 tinas d'accord
allez c'est parti en qui allez c'est
parti khédive et de velma assez pour
vous voilà la boiboite alors au moins à
belmont et duboscq la une une à une la
une
tiens ma chérie tu as là une voie là
c'est pour toi c'est qu'elle suive une
rhétorique et partir sur l'a3 l'a3
allemand apparaît vous par ci paraît
vous sur france 3 merci à l'éprouvant on
va refaire le tour jean michel mr bah je
voulais la trois ans je prends de la
manif 11
non vraiment non mais non
la deux la 2e mathieu que tu veux l'a86
l'a6 et la 4
[Rires]
l'a8 l'a6 et la 4a temps à la quatre
voies la baryte l'a8 allait très bien et
qui a émergé vol 5 5
moi je vous le dise mais je suis
toujours dernier mais c'est pas gagné
moi la saison
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà que vous êtes
on va démarrer pas les règles est-ce
qu'en 2019 vous allez arrêter tricher ou
pas non je n'ai jamais jamais cru chez
retirer ça tout de suite si jamais
triché je ne triche pas et vous savez
chez vous pas du tout les règles les
règles sont claires c'est moi qui l'ait
fait et vous jouez le droit de changer
de boîte alors combien de fois vous a le
droit de changer de boîte quand je le
dirai et excusez moi vous êtes qui vous
êtes du christ avec ses clients salamane
fois combien de fois en équipe à lyon
ces deux fois trois fois et on a le
droit de faire je le faisais je veux
démarrer par voie jamais demandé la tête
alors on regarde dans l'absolu tout à
fait chalabre ne voulait pas changer
mais bon on y va dire y allez on y va
durer pas du tout je ne sais pas ce que
dans la boîte je vous dire tout de suite
parce que là ça va aller me wade benhaim
vous avez gagné comme cadeau de noël
parce que je donne des cadeaux de noël
et la personne qui misaient sur bwin via
durant le même cadeau qu'elle vient
notre dû alors c'est parti on y va
beinheim vous avez gagné mon cul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
beynat il va gagner une console nouvelle
génération
[Applaudissements]
elle vient de dire laganière près mon
fils on rappelle bien sûr que son fils à
48 donc la console nouvelle génération à
free y allez c'est parti on va aller
maintenant du côté de chez vous devant
nani de chez vous fabien lecoeuvre wes
qui garde la deux moi j'aime bien la
200ème bien la 2e tu peux la sonde
je n'en veux pas changer je suis prêt je
peux presque
[Rires]
alors qu'est ce que tu veux mon courage
à la changer ou pas je ne sais pas je ne
sais plus je suis donc je vais la garder
ça je vais la garder mais je la garde
je la garde c lagarde en stock celle où
les lagarde et isabelle morini-bosc la
une avec moi je la garde
moi j'adore le chiffre 1 babarit vous
sur tf1 z'êtes sûr izama chien oui je
suis sur certaines âmes et oui c'est sûr
d'être en fait des mauvais choix gigamon
en carrière et sur l aimera qui chérit
cuisse et voilà merci
alors tu es sûr de prendre la mine oui
tu es sur ben oui doute isabelle maury
vote à vous repartez avec non au maire
[Applaudissements]
yannick salabert pas réglé
je vais maintenant ouvrir la boîte de
vous de moi
vous voyez bien chier à l'algérie nous
avons des pas si je vais changer
justement à manquer également changer de
mec non arrive pour l'heure brasse hier
garde du corps de kellermann il aurait
fait que se passe-t-il si une personne
comme ludivine maxime par exemple l'état
gagne donc un prime time il n'en a pas
les compétences le pire sur cette
séquence pourquoi imaginer avec vous
votre carrière
maintenant non allez je garde garde
c'était mon choix vide est pas question
et votre rêve comme cadeau à partir avec
vous au soleil c'est vrai wallez bull
air de minutes avec toi c'est à priori
rien de mal ça allait mal non y'a pas de
mal voilà il ya trois balles et bien sûr
en tout bien tout honneur et
applications frères et soeurs vivait les
chéris jeu sur tu gardes la 3 e divine
on fait fuiter ludivine oui on va
enchaîner que les beaux cadeaux
malheureusement non on avait changé de
façon vannerie ya un cadeau
malheureusement de quoi vous lier tous
que le divine va avoir non pas un
déguisement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tc
des cadeaux et au tu te calmes non mais
je me suis calmé d'hier n'étaient pas
l'état mais oui je sais allez on y va
maintenant je castaldi jouvray montiel
tient un horaire montiel a battu c'était
moi non montiel c'est lui ou celle de
leurs maux montiel a pris la boîte
numéro de leur copie vous ne demandez
pas si je vais à changer d'ici est ce
que vous voulez changer votre boîte et
ben non
pourquoi à parce que non bah voila moi
je te dis que tu vas changer ta boîte à
savon et hemani payant pour moi ou
est-ce que c'est malveillant motte alors
je te dis la vérité
dernier fait ce que tu veux à ton avis
que je t'aime que je t'aime pas ben je
crois que tu m'aimes
et comme tu veux oh il ya un truc avec
lui il pressent que tu veux ta boîte
berne à 7 soit bon allez je change la
non tu la veux cette boîte tu la veux
prend là vous êtes bienveillant avec moi
oui donc si je loupe ces biens n'ont pas
vraiment qu'il en avait quatre années
mais après avec bernard je suis sûr qu
un bain je change
tu vas me regarder droit dans les yeux
car à cognin savoie du méchant requin
boîte ferme était une pression c'est
noël lui font pas confiance c'est ce que
tu veux comme brassens
tfou change si tu veux me le salaire
garde ton courage barre mais quelle
boîte soit toi mais la 2 soit wanna know
him toi on peut c'est bien sûr qu'on
peut tous faire ici ce que voulait la
vie j'ai pas le choix
[Rires]
tu vois la butte où tu pas autre chose
non mais là vu tu me va bien tous pas
d'avis voilà la donne oui oui c'est sûr
ah oui je te laisse une dernière chance
de gestion enfin en quoi ces reliques
frontières oui tu veux la 8e se révèle à
je revenais à 8,15 à huit mois
non pardon baptiste de l'avion avec qui
vola mythe maintenant le plus rapide à
dire qu'ils veulent ami tu prends la 8c
maxime bois tu veux la [ __ ] et bat aura
la vie tu dors je garde la 2de perçu il
avait dit que la marée sur wii et la ds
tu vois là deux oui c'est sûr oui la vie
oui bravo montiel a et mahfoud et
bouchent les oreilles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'on a battue chérie que ces gens qui
savent où bébé très contente très très
joli cheval très bien en plus c'est ça
que l'ademe c4 et avoue que dans tes
oreilles avec le micro s'est fait le
mérite au lycée moi que je m'approche je
suis inquiète pas vas-y toi comme tu le
sens toi t'es gentille ont dû chantôme à
la coop et sireuil contre la lgv asie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout ça donne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
emma à entrer dans les camps soit le
christ a sorti son premier single c'est
plus facile avec mon lev et mac est avec
toi chérie
mes chéris mais c est mature axe avec
nous on va sonner ma part veut pas
revenir avec nous dans un instant emma
merci les séries où tu es trop mignonne
aller l'algérie l'a8 lavit ce que vous
la garde alors là c'est l'angoissé lavit
je suis je fais un choix je vais la
conserver un numéro non moi jamais je
suis plus sûr vous là je suis passé chez
raymond est ce que tu peux garder la
dise quel serait le plus beau cadeau
pour toi moi la partager de salaire avec
la personne de droite tu meurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien
et moi ce que tu gardes la lys non je
pense pas que c'est ta boîte que je veux
ouvrir la 1c je pense pas je verrai kg
avec la 9 balles alors alors lançant la
dre la tua par la dass vous pouvez la
douleur voilà c'est comme cela que sa
musique a dégoûté moi aussi je te jure
sur les goûts mais la saveur est
regardée l'a9 pour l'instant je garde la
9 parisien le club de la voûte la vie
rude et l'a vite j'ai envie de conserver
la huit mois c'est l'assemblée invite ce
serait quoi ton cadeau idéal partagé mon
papy quel salaire de ma part oui
ah oui bah tu vas aller mais personne ne
veut partir en vacances à ses messages
adorait j'adorais partir en vacances
chez moi je sais pas encore on l'a
jamais fait alors on l'a jamais faire
les mécanos toit commun à six si on est
parti aussi mais moi ça n'a rien à
[ __ ] à bien fabien tu es sûr que tu
gardes l'a vite tu peux reprendre la
neuve tutour prendre la 10e rencontre à
neuf girouette donc toi c'est dingue de
toi tu peux pas savoir ce qu'on veut
dans les attentions
allez c'est parti ça c'est vraiment tu
gardes l'a vite tu me saoules pas des
jouets milieu de terrain j'ai du mal à
me to pas moi j'ai déjà joué diego et or
est ce que tu es mon frère ville gardant
les références de garde à vue c'est un
avis tu veux la butte car de l'avis très
content et confiant
mais non si tu veux pas tu me dis parce
que moi j'ai jamais joué les gauches
céréales étaient sûrs alors tu balances
bien sûr entendre à la salle et ses
compères ou pas c'est la honte sur lt
théophraste et micron l'habitat pris la
route
si vous employez on est en direct et
c'est bien sûr c'est vraiment vous
attendez comme chaque saison les boîtes
de noël pour savoir quel cadeau ils vont
gagner quel cadeau de noël ils vont
gagner ya des très beaux cadeaux encore
et vous jouez avec nous sur twitter
#matin1 plus bien entendu le nom d'un
chroniqueur pour gagner le même cadeau
qu il reste un bouche-à-bouche derrière
un beau choc bus sont à sa bouche à
bouche avec l'abus ce1 sextos de noël la
phase de sapins un robot de cuisine
magnifique sassard s'intéresse à la
pique et le salaire du jour de la
personne à votre droite
un week end au soleil avec je vous
accompagnerai et co animer un prime en
2020 avec mauvaise versailles et moi je
suis très heureux de tous ces cadeaux
est ce que ces cadeaux sont aussi
mécaniquement et mon ami celui que je
connais depuis le plus de temps comme
beinheim c'est vraiment à mon ami j'ai
un ami raymond avant d'être un collègue
et un ami il ya un instant j'ai mis
notre amitié à rude épreuve avait choisi
la ville voilà je lui ai dit oui elle
m'a dit non au football le football à 9
oui mais le dieu des shows de numéro 8 a
vu ce qu'il a fait pas faux championnat
c'est pas fini
tu as choisi de prendre la boîte 11 oui
j'avais su que c'est parce qu'il ya
dedans elle avait changé voulais tu as
changé et a pris la 9 lavit la ronce
tous bousculé dans ta tête tu es sûr de
prendre 1 ou je ne sais même plus ce que
tu dis non je ne suis pas sûr car la
poule g hydrate et j'ai bu de l'eau
comme un sportif
oui mais j'ai retrouvé mes esprits et
j'ai revu votre regard quand vous m'avez
dit l'a8
oui et j'en vos yeux j'ai vu qu'il y
avait là métier dans vos yeux
oui et le temps de la pub qui parce que
l'été spectateurs savent c'est très long
la pub bien certes je suis sûr qu'ils
aient un truc dans l'a8
malheureusement c'est terminé
au nom de l'amitié non mais sans rire je
ne peux pas parce qu'il est dans des
magouilles c'est la première fois qu'on
aura vu ça dans stan on ya pas moyen n'a
pas regardé choisi avant la mer oui oui
je sais pas pour la déception tu fais ta
part de dessin c'est tout vraiment la
vraie montée chez mots nomades annoncé
poisson alors vraiment gagner c'est bien
là la phase de sa part
[Applaudissements]
joseph battre le fer regarder on va le
transformant sa pensez-vous pas tous
vers 17h à voile à relever comme ça et
voilà
regardez voilà une petite poudre à une
petite boule faire pour gérer
le potassium habitants allez merci
aulas
merci je me ferais ça merci rob a
annoncé au nom
bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci le grinch mégalomane les wc à
maxime gay ni cool avec maxime gagny
mais si elle est la 5
quel est votre rêve vous aimeriez gagner
quelques années j'aimerais bien rbo de
cuisine tu sais que ça fait pas for
maggi oui est-ce que vous gardez la cinq
où aller franchement comme le hasard
n'existe pas je vais conserver la
ceinture est très bien il confie maxime
tu sais que je t'aime
maxime est sûre tu veux la 5
moi je suis sûr regarde bien dans mes
yeux annonce à la 8
alors la huitième france amuf a va être
un cauchemar t'as vu que je veux dit
l'a8 a pas voulu d'habitants tu aimerais
bien vite cc by way est ce qu'on
travaille sur un cinq noms n'ont pas
encore en train de refaire un prime
c'est pas la première fournée ce que je
veux c'est certain de voir quoi c'est
que tu veux pas avoir de concurrent
cependant le coni masr le rsa c'est le
dc100 voilà une excellente saison et
même du seul mandat le 21 décembre les
magiciens du monde merci c'est vrai
bravo malaisie selon maximus alors je
vais changer
je connais l'état je sens une autre
conseil ne sais que vous l'avez déjà vu
et comme vous êtes de bons conseils
maxime est ce que julien david noël toi
maxime ou si vous avez votre moyenne 8
c'est fais moi un écran plat pour
l'ouvrir devrait pas manquer ferme et
renonce à tokyo
max et les cheveux la [ __ ] me
franchement j'en doute mais ouais tu
veux te robot je veux mon repos maxime
bohler l'habite foulée que ce soit
raymond qu'il apprenne jeter un il va
mettre ce soir et vous qui la prennent
carrément la mériter c'est clair maxime
tu repars avec le salaire du lièvre
[Applaudissements]
le 10 mai
oui il aurait pris mon salaire oui il
m'a dit tom jomby je travaille et que tu
dis aux mateurs castaldi vous connaissez
le principe pour jouer dans ce jeu là je
veux la capte bien sûr donc celle de
lambeaux bien sûr mais ça ne te donnera
ni mon talent ni ma carrière on voulait
vingt quatre savez quoi
j'ai même pas envie de jouer avec vous
bah oui dont c'est la merde alors il est
pas du tout la perversion vous savez
quoi ouais
regardez-moi droit dans les yeux ça
l'est mais c'est pas de la mer à deux
semaines à metz un robot de cuisine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
robot et surtout d'un robot de cuisine à
la fois la can make de 30 ans rêve d'un
robot mois où les trente ans non tu veux
tirer c'est maintenant à mon amie et ma
boîte c'était c'était votre boîte
septfonds officiers ou par le présent
par le passé on parle au futur on
utilise tous les temps par tous les
temps oh c'est pas bien tout va bien le
curve un ami la petite est fabien
lecoeuvre
vous aviez au départ j'avais pris quoi
la donne la deux qui est parti qu'ils
avaient le sécher qui a boosté ma ale
aujourd'hui j'ai pris la 9 fabien
qu'est ce que tu aimerais avoir comme
cadeau un week-end akbar mais choisi la
destination à manawan et où c'est dans
son cul venir dans son clip
[Applaudissements]
et pourquoi pas là mais j'adore voyager
bien on vit nu une semaine tu veux le
voyage ou ouais non mais franchement est
ce que tu gardes de cette boîte ou pas
ouais je conserve ma boîte je te le
donne comme un con comme un service fort
je la change pas du tout d'accord dont
je la garde les calculs il ne sait pas
ce qu'il ya dedans je ne sais pas ce qui
est don salluste et pas ouverte
passons le pire maintenant ses poèmes
c'est et le sexto noël un droit sont
leurs cinq jeux c'est ce qui a arrêté
mais n'allez pas ouverte mais par des
débats boîte
[Musique]
méchanceté gratuite
[Rires]
quand chef alors grand chef je sais que
vous ne trichez jamais imaginé juste
pour vous et la chaîne si on associe
qu'on additionne mes fans et les vôtres
sur un prime time
j'imagine les faits devant son écran là
il ne veut pas ces primes alors allez je
vais demander mieux demander à l'efa
bien ce que tu allais chéri jolie je
vais faire cet ordre là je vais faire un
deux trois quatre
tout est ce que vous gardez votre cabane
à nice
est-ce que je dois la gare de pas non
j'ai pas regardé avec alors je prends la
dix ans décide des kékés la partie
voiture on fait comme ça c'est vous qui
choisissez des changes la garde pas ah
ben moi quand je peux plus je peux dire
qu'une fois battant c'est nouveau ah oui
c'est ça
ce chiffre peut dire qu'on voit ici ton
père bachet nolan à neuf ballons alors à
l'état doit encore une fois elle n'a
fait grandir une fois aller je prends le
9 trous maire de beausoleil se serait
alors l'acte est super scène de kevin
anin et tu fais est-ce que tu gala neuf
ou pas je te regarde là pour l'instant
c'est fini tu vas pas changer sans foi
t'a pris l'habitude cas madoff a les
instruments
j'ai exhorté la ligue à tours nomades ce
jeu le garde dadis se garde l'a dit si
tu veux quoi non pas bien tu es sûr cela
est sur toi c'est bon allez fabien on va
se faire à qui tous les deux je te le
dis voilà un texto de noël
[Applaudissements]
il enverra sextos dans un instant en
plus j'ai un carnet d'un réseau et le
monde tu vas devoir envoyer le mot tu
vas devoir envoyer à une personne très
très connu de droiture toit à quatre
mètres pour noël pour noël j'ai très
envie de passer par la cheminée mais non
je savais pas de vélib temps la nuit
alors il s'est fait il veut la dope
raison à récupère sa boîte of men on
garde la 10 enfin la garde la 5g droite
changer une fois je dis bien une fois ce
que vous gardez là 9 selon vous d'aller
regarder ou pas je vous ai déjà dit je
dois vous dire une chose mais vous
m'avez dit la changer l'a5 way changer
là
[Rires]
je la change lâche après faut voir si je
suis sincère ou pas toujours très bien
compris ce qui se passait et bah du coup
je regarde à bon port la confiance règne
graf ge et dernier jeu prend la 6 la
bande à elle a raison je sais laquelle
je veux un voulé laquelle vous
c'est une révélation divine c'est quoi
parfaire le problème c'est quoi c'est
bien mal que je sache encore si vous
voulez laquelle neuf dragons et pluie
le chargeur fait pas ses jambes ça c'est
rêver que j'ai dit je vais faire
alors que personne ne change rien du
tout j'aimerais juste récupérer mon bien
l'a9 depuis le début ça fait bizarre
mais c'est après l'état une boîte à gala
la boucle est bon mais je vais vous dire
elle a du talent mais les chéris on va
faire un jeu va faire un jeu et je vous
dire celui qui tombera aura le droit de
choisir en premier et le deuxième en
deuxième le troisième en quatre matches
a marqué pas mal ça va faire votre
modère le dos au jeu rédémarrer de
mathieu de leur bon ouais ça allait
faire un chiffre de 0 à 5 cers comme ça
il ya cinq doigts ça tombe bien
[Rires]
la traite et de demain
j'ai dit et je n'y prête attention je
vais partir de match énorme où je vais
compter et donc la servir si on arrive à
12 et que j'arrive sur matthieu
delormeau
enfin attention 3 2 ap
ce qui fait qu'à trois quatre cinq six
barrettes
non ça compte mais non mais non bassett
et là mais on fait une tt était à 7
après c'est tombé sur moi
comment poussière et l'eurofoot ngokwey
alors on la refait pays où l'arche pas
mais non tu as eu ton direct là les
toits non en direct pas d'inquiétude
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
thomson foutrais noël en l'air j'ai
gagné j'ai gagné je garde la neuve c'est
chaud là où tu dirais qu'il ya des
règles des règles soient pas non plus
d'adn n'a laissé lui le nord les
simulations place du coup de gueule a
passé six mois là vous de choisir celle
à 6 ou la 500 balles à 9 mai elle
comprend aussi un fusain avec ça c'est
lassant qu'au début toi tu
non non non vous n'êtes que deux
magasins c'était moi le premier alors on
est parti
voilà voilà donc tu vas pas si évident à
weekend de soleil est bas qu ib ibrahim
en 2020 avec baba et un bouche à bouche
les chéris
j'aurais d'abord votre boîte quevedo v10
vous aviez l'a6 vous avez choisi la 5ème
et la scène britannique change et baba
ici toujours l'amérique vous aviez la
fin je vous ai dit non palacin klein oui
ces échanges avaient fait vous en avez
fait qu'à votre texte
comme toujours il y avait dominique
comme d'habitude on le dit quelque chose
elle peut compter ça sent la bûche
crédit va nous aider mais la bûche
bouteille sans faille je suis chez mes
débuts j'ai aimé le bûcher bouche non
non pas ça pour elle les névés de redire
oui
[Applaudissements]
je l'avais dit que le propre voix ça
m'apprendra des collègues avec nous pour
l'instant
laissez-nous finir le jeu et ont pour
certaines déjà il ya une personne qui a
misé sur vous ah ouais il va être tirés
au sort sur twitter qui gagne on avait
beaucoup misé sur moi bah oui eh ben
c'est au plus le savez j'avais 18 h
ouais janvier vous avez pris la 6
mathieu dandenault vous avez pris la 9
il ne reste ça me soit 7,9 le don c'est
vrai tu fais toi
il s'entraîne huit séries il attendait
parce que je crois que j'ai un texto de
la chaîne sera mieux habillée c'est pas
des ce sera dès janvier le prendre là
c'était des essais rapides je prendre
aie aie aie aie aie aie
la chaîne demande à ce qu'on annule le
jeu elle me dit on est on est on est va
mettre la clé sous la porte
mathieu jean mi il reste de bois
une boîte dans laquelle il y à un bouche
à bouche
c'est à dire faire du bouche à bouche à
une bûche jouer avec la langue mais avec
la mort impossible tu la mets partout un
an et il ya un deuxième cadeau co animer
un prime avec ba ba ouai je vais est-ce
que vous avez une préférence vous seriez
d'ailleurs je crois que oui bien sûr que
oui la bûche à la bûche presse
l'autorité de référence
je vais demander aux chroniqueurs je
vais faire un tour de table et je vais
demander aux téléspectateurs aussi s'il
a choisi entre jean louis et matthieu
pour la coanimation le temps que ce tour
de table choisir et qui mathieu ou gens
ne vous votez sur twitter
pour le moment vous gens me mathieu
[Rires]
trésorier qui se serait nouveau jambiers
oui j'avais fait ma nage à nous il est
sûr mais nous avons envie du prime très
bientôt
oui c'était plus voyage de la bien moi
je pense qu'avec delormeau ça peut faire
un très bon prime et vous quel est
inséré mathieu parce qu'il y en a plus
envie je pense mathieu bonjour juste que
voilà mufasa ce sont un petit peu menacé
par simba mais malgré tout des moteurs
avec ce qu'il a moi je dirais mathieu
parce qu'il en rêve vraiment il a
vraiment envie de le faire isabelle
hains guy maintien puis je penserai la
nef si le prime la prime à la jeunesse
sont michel
lorient est drôle c'est même tu fous là
je sais pas tu avais des marchés je
reviens pas sur le cul bon bah je sais
pas à jean louis malle toi le cul
janvier a des petits soucis d'élocution
c'est ça qui est embêtant mais on a les
salaires c'est comme si je t'emmerde
[Rires]
team on m'a toujours dit dans l'humour
il fouette où tout en haut tout en bas
jean-mi avec toi d2 c'est magnifique et
je suis tombé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
plutôt mes chéris alors ce soir me
disent les gens ont ri les
téléspectateurs alors leur avis est
important
il aimerait que ce soit qui en régie
vous êtes endormi
oui bah c'est maintenant alors gens me
le prime où le bouche à bouche
mathieu a tué le prime où le bouche à
bouche pas que je vais demander une
dernière fois en suisse c'est toi qui
avais gagner pour le tirage au sort
mathieu gardes tu la boîte numéro 9
turlututu chapeau pointu
alors je te dire c'est rare que je sois
à ce point mais le père de mpt aux
hypers perm thouars oui de prime time et
dans la 9 e pense aussi je peux déjà
prévenir le real cam à fond sur moi les
autres étoiles jaunes alors vous êtes de
parfaits d'être défaite en finale des
boîtes n'avait jamais gagné
est-ce que vous continuez à suivre votre
instinct merci de rappeler peut-être aux
téléspectateurs qui arrivent et qui
n'avaient pas suivi des émissions
précédentes mais ça c'est la victoire
c'est la 7e victoire c'est sûr de ça
matthieu delormeau sur j'ai pas le
moindre doute la 9e cette boîte que vous
voulez depuis le début elle boite qui
était au départ la boîte de kelly vdo
v10 et venir et qui ensuite est passé
chez fabien lecoeuvre qui ensuite est
passé chez jean michel maire oui c'est
une boîte qui a beaucoup tourné pour
revenir ensuite chez vous mathieu
delambre cette boîte vous la voulez
cette boîte vous la voulez cette boîte
vous allez la voir
dans la gueule exact cette voie vous
allez la voir mathieu et mathieu c'était
ma voix hachée ou le bouche à bouche ou
le voyage
ah non non time avec moi dès janvier
quoi dès janvier
[Applaudissements]
mathieu bien sûr que vous ne voulez pas
changer une dernière fois
il est sur moi je peux te demander
quelque chose oui tu peux fermer ta
gueule et beauté c'est mon moment j'en
ai gardé dans le sondage mais tout est
de leur mort serait ce que parce que le
hasard a suivi un pipi ou est ce que le
hasard si dit non non je veux vivre ma
vie je marche seul faux rebelle jean
jacques goldman mathieu sachez le
une fois de plus comme il y avait eu du
pif mais je promets que si cette salle
mathieu mathieu c'est pas vrai si ce
n'est pas le prime time vous partez à je
peux vraiment à oui ça arrangerait pas
mal de nature une fois de plus vous avez
eu du pif et ce qu'ils font on vérifiera
dans hannah du monde nous rejoigne et
sachez qu'ils s'en est passé des choses
la somme fait une paroisse de photos
faisant le jeu des boîtes
et et matthieu delormeau brève de co
animer un problème avec moi en 2020 sur
s'est vite
matthieu delormeau qu'on appelle dans le
milieu des boîtes la thur la loose dans
le finaliste fait druelle à mathieu la
loose centre e entretien
rarement les finalistes sa part qu à
part quand y mettre un coup de boule à
alors vous avez pris chiche donc vous
vous avez là 9,1 et non même si lent
mais non non c'est moi la wii c'est
comme moi oui donc oui si c'est
difficile de s'en tirer
mathieu est ce que derrière la daf il ya
le prime time
ont-ils changé juste pour la victoire
matthieu delormeau il reste le bouche à
bouche et le prime time
talbot a indiqué à l'ats discours s'est
jamais gagné 0,2 pourquoi c'est d'abord
par les gossip matthieu delormeau
je vous le dis derrière l'a9 il y a et
je n'ai pas triché mathieu sèvres je
n'ai rien fait je vous ai conseillé de
prendre l'a6 battu maintes et maintes
fois mathieu vous le voulez ce prime un
vous le voulez ce prime mathieu non je
le voulais ce prix me mathieu répondre
oui je lai et l'a9 ça et c'est bien là 9
on dira que c'est bien la 9ème elle à
l'envers donc votre cadeau il est bien
derrière la 9.9 ça oui c'est la 9 au
maire 9
vous l'avez yes
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans la nuit le jour du printemps
terre battue je suis très heureux de
coanimer après mais avec toi ce sera en
janvier on va faire un carton et cdma
bois très très très heureuse niveau de
gâter votre voix de kelly
malheureusement et c'est mathieu qui va
quoi animer le prime avec moi ce sera
dès janvier je suis très heureux mon
chéri les chéris fin d'année voilà de
fou l'infraction il se passe plein de la
bûche je me lemaire
[Rires]